what is he doing here  we found your daughter she's alive  be prepared for changes we have a child  therapist that she'll be working with  four years is a long time what she needs  right now is our family mr  sweetheart  it's mommy  welcome home esther we left it just as  it was  it's lovely to be back i miss my family  very much  our goal here is helping esther  acclimate back into life within the  family unit  [Music]  sorry  i think something's going on with esther  is there anything you want to tell me  about your time away  how's that possible four years ago she  was still drawing stick figures  esther's behavior has been so erratic  hello mommy  thank you mommy  i did notice some  what are inconsistencies getting at  to me it felt like a performance  if you're not esther who are you  [Music]  i need it for you  [Music]  [Applause]  the mother protects her family  no matter  that's the what of love  you